donc eh bien il s'agit à nouveau de vous
proposer une possibilité de recettes
supplémentaires avec une contribution
exceptionnelle sur les fonds de pension
je ne vais pas argumenter à l'infini
j'imagine que vous allez me répondre
qu'il faut pas y toucher donc si je
résume notre débat les revenus
financiers des entreprises faut pas y
toucher les revenus du patrimoine faut
pas y toucher l'argent des milliardaires
faut pas y toucher les dividendes faut
pas y toucher les super profits faut pas
y toucher la flat tax qui protège les
revenus des gros actionnaires faut la
protéger et là les fonds de pension vous
allez me dire faut pas y toucher donc en
gros vous dites français travaillez deux
ans de plus parce que faut protéger les
revenus financiers des entreprises les
revenus du patrimoine ceux des
milliardaires les dividendes les super
profils à flat tax et les fonds de
pension voilà en gros la synthèse du
débat qu'on a depuis deux heures alors
moi je dis aux Français je dis aux
Français vous allez manifester par
millions demain parce qu'ils sont
nombreux à nous écouter et bien vous
avez raison de manifester parce que
manifestement il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent pour financer votre retraite
[Applaudissements]
le 25 19